there's a mythic quality to transformers
and it speaks to me it speaks to a lot
of the fans
[Music]
hi i'm matt home executive producer of
transformers war for cybertron trilogy
and this is every Transformers
generation so transformers has evolved
significantly since it first started in
1984 there have been a whole host of
series and films and each one of these
is broken up into what fans talk about
as a generation Transformers generation
one 1984 to 1993
so transformers the TV show ran from
1984 to 1987 it was based on a toy line
that ran from 1984 to 1990 produced by
Hasbro of course and Takara it
accompanied the toy line the cartoon set
up the basic story of transformers that
most other incarnations were going to
follow as two warring factions of robots
on the planet Cybertron and they leave
in search of resources the factions
crash-landed on earth and millions of
years later begin their battle anew
they're going at it
through time through space it's epic
everything about it is epic so that
early series introduced a number of the
iconic characters that we all still know
and love and are so integral to
transformers during Optimus Prime has
just you know this incredible leaders
makes these resonant giant speeches and
inspires everybody by kitronik must be
stopped
no matter that cause he's not just a
hero that goes out and punches people in
battles
he's like a thinker he is absorbed with
the ethical and moral quandary
and battling his fellow transformers he
wants to do the right thing where the
right thing is not always easy to see
but he keeps a prime moral code to
himself you know all sentient beings
deserve freedom and that we should all
be unified to all - oh those are really
powerful things that resonate that's the
great thing about the Transformers I
think that Optimus Prime really
encapsulates as a character but it's
about doing what's right and it's about
doing what's just Optimus Prime will be
glad to see us bumblebee who was always
that lovable sidekick
good to know and in the early extremes
bumblebee was a Volkswagen Beetle and we
had a yellow Volkswagen Beetle in my
family at the house and so it was nice
to have my own bumblebee it never
transformed for me
a disappointment but like to having that
connection that guy's side you know
Decepticons you got Megatron you get
Starscream you got a sound wave also
evil also wonderful hope and how evil
that they are but I think the biggest
moment for me and my early love of
Transformers was going to see the movie
in the theater
[Music]
[Applause]
I remember so well going to see this
movie and I had a couple friends you
know who were really into transformers
as well and we were just blown away I
just remember being in the theater and
thinking like this is the greatest film
that will ever be made in the history of
time it has everything you could
possibly want there's a mythic quality
to transformers and it speaks to me it
speaks to a lot of the fans you know to
generation 1 of Transformers spoke to me
he spoke to a lot of people because the
themes were just really big and
universal and you felt connected to them
and then they would do things you know
that you really hadn't seen in it in a
kid's show a cartoon before today an
Autobot shall rise from our ranks and
use the power of the matrix to light o
darkest
having Optimus Prime die in a moment of
self-sacrifice in the movie was really
powerful and also something that in some
ways you know aged up this story for
kids who felt like me and they want to
see something more than what something
was more depth out of their their
entertainment I always loved that and
inspired me inspired us to try to put
more elements like that you know into
the story I love that movie so much and
I've always wanted to work on anything
related to transformers
[Applause]
transformers Headmaster's supplanting
the rebirth and Japanese continuity the
Headmaster's occurred one year after the
return of Optimus Prime
introducing the title characters to the
Transformers Universe in a totally
different way the Headmaster's of the
Japanese series are a group of small
Cybertronians who departed the planet
millions of years ago and crash-landed
on the inhospitable planet master to
survive its harsh climate a select few
Cybertronians constructed larger bodies
called trade sectors to which they
connected as the heads there was a very
obvious effort on head writer Masumi
canada's part to make master force a
fresh start as a mecha story introducing
an entirely new cast of characters from
scratch rather than using any of the
previous ones i guess one of the things
that's it's so interesting about this
the Japanese offshoot of transformers is
that it does show what a big world this
is to play in and how much opportunity
there is to tell a lot of different
stories and these characters really have
another depth to them and I've been
drawn out well enough that you can take
them in a lot of different directions
transformers generation to 1993 to 1995
g2 was a Transformers toy line which ran
from 1992 to 1995 in conjunction with a
corresponding comic book series and
edited reruns of the g1 cartoon
so the smattering of CGI animation
played on topic this was the only change
in the content how weird is that but it
made a whole new series that was the
same except for a couple
I think so although there wasn't a whole
lot of change this is where the concept
of generations came from and fans
started to differentiate between
different eras of Transformers which
would become really important for
understanding the story in the universe
over time
[Applause]
[Music]
these wars transformers 1996 and 1999
the series is set in the future of the
original Transformers franchise
generation 1 and features the maximals
and predacons new factions who have
inherited the mantle of the Autobots and
Decepticons respectively while engaged
in battle the maximals and predacons for
each faction crash-land on an unknown
planet which is revealed to be earth and
let's find a way to return home while
continuing their war beast era is also
the first time you see Transformers turn
into something that's on a machine into
these beasts if you think about even the
Dinobots there are machines of some type
but now you've got a wholly new way in
era for the Transformers to metamorphose
to transform as they do and that's
another thing that really adds a lot of
complexity and depth to the Transformers
Universe you know I think one of the
reasons Beast war is important for
transformers overall is that it
introduced a lot of new elements they
really expanded on the Canon
and they progressed the story forward so
I think for a lot of fans Beast Wars is
great because it really gave the
Transformers Universe
more depth more breadth took you places
that you hadn't seen before and that's
really fun so this series is really
unique and that it advances the
Transformers Canon forward but still
touches upon what made the original
series so special you see how the
Transformers species of all over time
letting you see what happens after the
original series but you still get a
glimpse of what happened at the very
beginning of generation one one moment
in particularly highlights this when the
maximals find the Autobots ark the
maximals know they need to protect their
past to save their future and before
they leave the ark Optimus Prime opens
his eyes and connects with Optimus
Primal connecting the two leaders over
time so one really important piece of
the Transformers backstory to understand
and to know about is the ark the ark was
the autobot ship that they took from
Cybertron to escape being exterminated
essentially by the Decepticons they made
it all the way across the universe to
earth they crash-landed and then they
were asleep for millions of years and
didn't wake up until present day 1984
when the Transformers generation one
story begins I really do love the ark
storyline and you know the Transformers
being asleep for millions of years
because they're both really suggestive
of other mythic stories you know you
think of like Sleeping Beauty and you
think of Noah's Ark in the Bible and you
think of these tales that have been told
throughout time there's a very see you
know Homeric kind of quality to their
journey that's something that you don't
usually see woven into a cartoon that
was aimed at kids and you know really
promoting a toy line it's a it's a
connecting thread that kind of ties all
of the worlds of Transformers and the
autobots and decepticons storylines
together over time
what characters can you name in any
other kid show that have a backstory
that lasts literally millions of years
they've gone through time they've gone
through space they've done everything
you can possibly imagine to end up in
the moment bear in now that's what makes
this all so epic beast wars - the anime
uses conventional animation rather than
the CGI of its predecessor beast wars -
tells the story of a battle raging
between Leo convoys team of Cybertron's
and galvatron's army of des Tron's on
the planet Gaea as Leo convoy and
Galvatron fight of the mysterious energy
source known as in gamma energy I think
that mythic quality is one of the
reasons that has spoken to Japanese
audiences spoken to American audiences
speaks to people around the world
because it really doesn't matter what
the setting and the dressing is you know
when you are telling stories and tales
that are literally told over generations
and go beyond the bounds of time you
know it invokes this heroic journey that
speaks to us know no matter what the
context is and the fact that they're
transforming robots is just I see
these machines transformers 1999 to 2000
direct sequel to American Beast Wars
taking place within the continuity of
the original transformer series the
maximals are back on Cybertron but have
suffered amnesia from the Beast Wars
saga don't you hate that when that
happens when you get amnesia in the
middle of your story what can you do it
also reverted transmittals optimus
cheetor Rattrap and black Arachnia back
to their original forms finding the
oracle underneath the city the maximals
are turned into techno organics to
survive the virus now they must master
their emotions in order to transform
again the maxim will soon learn that
Megatron got free mid-flight during
their time travel back to the future
ending up there long before they showed
up he conquered the planet and now he
plans to poke their sponsors viral
you've lost so the Beast era also
features the first fully CGI animated
Transformers and that's something that
really allowed the animators to try new
things get more expressive in their
action they could match the movements of
the characters better to the toys and
you can see the entire process of all
that's something that we wanted to do as
well with work for Cybertron make these
characters feel really real and grounded
emotionally but also physically make
them feel like you could see them in
real life and with CGI animation I think
we get closer to that and we've ever
gotten before
transformers Robots in Disguise from
2000 a KA transformers car robots robots
in disguise was a single animated series
consisting of 39 episodes in this
continuity Megatron recreates the
Decepticons as a sub faction of the
Predacons it was originally conceived as
a reboot of a self-contained universe
separate from any of the other existing
Transformers universes
it was later retconned as part of the
Japanese generation 1
one of the things that's interesting
about the way that they've released all
of these different Transformers series
is they don't stick with just one age
demo one type of storytelling throughout
these different generations the
Transformers is a very
multi-generational and very accessible
franchise because they've made some
shows that I think are for younger kids
and they've made others that are more
adult and then you've got the the movies
as well that kind of are four-quadrant
and accessible to everyone over time I
think has pros done some really smart
things where they've gone back and
essentially rebooted the show or retold
the show in a different way so the new
audiences can be brought in Autobots
live to help protect others
Predacons exist only to conquer and
destroy how am I supposed to know who to
trust people that they jump you know
they want to see different things out of
this universe as they get older the
younger generation kids who want to have
the same experience that that I did when
I was growing up and watching
transformers be introduced into this new
world that's accessible to them as long
as hatred exists I shall remain
impervious to attack peena-pod trilogy
Armada follows the autobots and
decepticons discovering that powerful
mini cons on earth which revealed to be
weapons of Unicron Energon said ten
years later followed the Autobots and
the Omni crowns in their fight to stop
the Decepticons from resurrecting
Unicron with Energon in Japan the series
transformers cybertron showed no ties to
the previous two series telling its own
story entirely
the writers attempted to change certain
plot elements from the Japanese version
to remedy this this largely added Upton
references to Unicron Primus primes and
many cons so now we've got an entire
trilogy that's based around Unicron it
was the first example I can think of
when I was a kid of seeing what's now
known as a super villain then me to be
the fish we did trucks transforming and
planes transforming but this is a guy
that can transform into entire planet he
is the ultimate super mega mecha villain
ever he's first introduced into the
Canon in the Transformers the movie they
really wanted something that was
larger-than-life the to be presented in
a larger-than-life format at the movies
and it worked
it was voiced by legendary actor and
director Orson Welles then lens that
gravitas you know in bravado and
everything else you would want out of a
performance to this character that would
just you know was designed to just
dominate what a time considered spelling
or wretched a planet Cybertron no you
shall witness its just remember modes of
life for fourteen years later from our
first introduction of Unicron and the
movie and now we've got an entire
trilogy based around Unicron and the
idea of Unicron is just so large it's
beyond the scope of anything we did seem
in transformers and the narrative before
so the war between the Autobots and
Decepticons all this time has not just
been you know actual physical battle
it's an ideological battle right there
fighting for like what do they believe
in what I do and now you introduce this
character of Unicron who is essentially
a god almost unstoppable and gives a new
dynamic to who you thought these
characters were in a density and
gigantic scale of what everyone is
fighting for one thing that is really
fun about transformers and interesting
is that the universe is so big now that
there are all of these things within it
characters places battles you know a lot
of history that you know you want to go
to and expand upon and and and learn
about and there are certain indelible
characters like Unicron that are so big
that they keep recurring at different
points through the history but I think
one of things that makes them special is
not overdoing it you want to have a
gigantic event for a particular
character that's worth the wait
it's a great thing if you don't overdo
it
[Music]
transformers the live-action film
franchise everybody knows these they are
gigantic over-the-top unbelievable like
the pinnacle of Hollywood filmmaking
essentially the work done by ILM is
something that nobody had ever seen at
this scale and size and complexity all
of the little details of each
transforming piece there's a lot of
humor in these films which is really
great I think one of the things that get
they got really right in this series
that I've always loved is that the human
characters they have some great dramatic
storylines and these films just give you
such a sense of scale for the first time
in live-action you're seeing humans
interacting with these CGI transformers
in a way that looks totally real you
really get to see what this would look
like in real life it's materialize the
way you kind of dream about a kid
playing with these these action figures
you you really since the drama and the
compelling epic war between the Autobots
and Decepticons you know they're just a
really fun ride all the way through so
the first movie was titled transformers
pretty straightforward that was in 2007
directed by Michael Bay he went around
to direct several more including revenge
of the Fallen in 2009 dark of the Moon
2011 age of extinction
and last night in 2017 the most recent
live-action Transformers movie was
directed by Travis Knight it's called
bumblebee a prequel to the other
Transformers movies goes back to the
eighties which is a really fun setting
for this movie we get to see how
bumblebee arrives on earth even though
their giant mega spectacles they also do
a lot of character work and a lot of
work in advancing the the narrative and
the story in the universe of
Transformers over time I think the film
series was so iconic and so beloved by
so many people because didn't matter
whether or not you knew transformers you
know to enjoy it and I think a lot of
people were introduced to Transformers
the very first time by this series and
you just have this gigantic scale it's
worthy of being in a movie theater at
being of it being cinema seeing the
scale with them against these human
backdrops these cities and smashing into
freeways and all the crazy stuff that
happens you really get a sense of just
how epic the entire design of this
universe is the design of the
Transformers was pretty different in the
live-action films but I think it really
worked because they were really
showcasing what they could do is CGI
you've had a lot of intricacy to these
models but I think gave them a sense of
realism that you maybe wouldn't have
been able to achieve if they had been as
had simplified lines as is appropriate
for a cartoon or any kind of animated
show thinking the end that serves the
purpose of making it feel real making it
feel grounded make it feel larger than
life all of the little mechanics and
turn and twist and transform feel real
and feel like they belong in the real
world the most recent live-action
Transformers movie bumblebee you may
remember the first five minutes this
incredible scene from Cybertron the
world just feels you know complete
sonically it's interesting visually it's
interesting everything about it has a
nice weight to it the characters have a
more defined gate I guess you could say
and we wanted to emulate that as as much
as you could the way the characters feel
I think is really important to their
believability
bumblebee just did a fantastic job with
all of that I think bumblebee is so
beloved because know he's loyal and
brave and kind of selfless at times but
he's still charming and funny and
unusual and you know he's been through
so many different iterations he's he's
kind of the perfect companion
transformers animated 2007 2003
Transformers Animated is set in 2050
Detroit 50 years after transformers
crash-landed on earth when robots and
humans live side-by-side
the Autobots assumed superhero roles
battling evil humans with the
Decepticons having a smaller bowl and so
Megatron resurfaces darn the Megatron
while the series is not a sequel to the
live-action movie they have many somatic
elements in common most notably the
central role of the Allspark and the
revelation that all modern technology
has been reverse-engineered from the
dormant body of Megatron
Transformers Animated is really
interesting in the era it lands because
2007 to 2010 is kind of the dawn of this
repr of the superhero across the
spectrum DC movies and Marvel movies
really took off and here you see
Transformers Animated do a lot of that
portraying these characters that we know
in more of a superhero type action than
before
[Music]
aligned University 2010 to present
Hasbro created the aligned universe
within a tip to unify all the
Transformers media into one single
continuity it's kind of a big task this
consists of two novels several video
games a few animated series along with
supplemental material let's start with
Transformers Prime from 2010
Transformers Prime focuses on the super
heroic Autobots of teen prime which
consists of Optimus Prime ratchet
Arcee bumblebee and bulkhead throughout
their battles the Autobots are aided by
three human children and with your help
attempt to protect the Earth from the
villainous Decepticons and their leader
Megatron the changes in additions the
series makes two Transformers Lord
include the ancient planet size
transformer Unicron serving as the core
of the earth itself emphasizing the idea
that earth and Cybertron are twin
planets mech any CH a human faction led
by the villainous Silas whose sole
purpose is to create a new world order
through cutting-edge technologies stolen
from the Transformers the necromantic
dark Energon a more unstable and
dangerous version of Energon which can
be used to bring the dead back to life
as mindless zombies called terrorcons
and the Predacons being the Transformers
ancestors haven't gone extinct until
they were recreated by shockwave to
serve the Decepticons this series does
everything it's got zombies it's got
Unicron being the core of the planet
amazing everything's crazy I have been
transformed in learning about this maybe
instead of calling it the aligned
universe they should have called it the
transforming universe because they've
taken all these pieces that are just so
amazing and mythic and they figured out
a way that they all make sense together
I don't know how they did it it's Kirk
Izzie transformers go from 2013 to 2014
transformers go is a Japanese exclusive
sequel to Transformers Prime beast
hunters there are two chapters Samurai
and shinobi both however share the same
basic plot to humans one descended from
a line of samurai action and one from
ninjas encountered the Predacons
attempting to steal powerful ancient
artifacts the legend disks to revive the
leader dragga Tron
however the disks summon two teams of
Autobots or pawns each corresponding to
the human partners ancestry from then on
with the help of Optimus Prime they come
bat the Predacons while attempting to
retrieve all of the legend discs
transformers RESCUE BOTS 2011 to 2012
this was aimed at a younger generation
Transformers fans unusual for a
transformers cartoon it features no
Decepticons no Decepticons though they
are mentioned from time to time well
okay I'll take a mention from time to
time affecting game transformers RESCUE
BOTS Academy 2019 to present the sequel
to transformers RESCUE BOTS so if you
think about the Alliant universe they
were doing a lot more than just figuring
out how all these disparate story
elements could somehow fit together into
a cohesive universe they also were
expanding on some of the ways that we
look at and think about transformers
there's more kid-friendly stories
there's you know these legendary and
kind of Japanese inspired stories and
somehow they all managed to not only
make the story element and the
characters fit together in a good
continuities way they also just broaden
your concept of what transformers can be
I think that's what makes it compelling
for anybody to come in and tell a story
and the transformer
Cybertron is in danger the peace treaty
has fallen apart the treaty was a false
hope we both knew that Transformers
Prime sucks drunken bird the first arc
of Transformers Prime Wars is the
combiner wars 40 years after the great
war between the Autobots and Decepticons
on earth two factions return to
Cybertron where Optimus Prime defeated
Megatron and a final duel ending their
war permanently a Council of worlds was
forged consisting of Rodimus Prime
Starscream and mistress of flames ruling
Cybertron and chemists in an uneasy
peace however the rise of the combiners
caused destruction and death on Canada's
setting windblade the city Speaker of
the Titans on a quest for vengeance
another mythic thing from Transformers
we have quests meanwhile the combiner
Victoria lines on our own mission to
find enigma of combination enigmas
quests are - Titans return following the
end of the combiner wars the Titans are
awakened and Trypticon begins to wreak
havoc on Cybertron to combat Trypticon
wind blade gathers up a raging team of
Transformers to resurrect an ancient
ally and while some may be forever
changed for the events others may not
emerge with their sparks intact our
three power of the primes following the
death Optimus Prime the rest of the
transformers was band together to
survive before mama Negatron us father
and wipe out their species
transformers cyber first 20 18 to 25
cyberverse uses characters and elements
across g1 East era the live-action film
series animated and the Alliant annuity
the series focuses on The Adventures of
bumblebee having damaged his memory
chips he and wind blades must recover
his missing memories in order to help
him remember his mission on earth
unfortunately the Decepticons are after
their friends the series is intended to
focus more on characters and their
mythology and utilizes the evergreen
character designs it is set a new
continuity and is not a sequel to any
previous series if you think back to
generation 1 and kind of all of the
Transformers animated series that you've
seen over time they're very much
episodic which is very common
storytelling from the era that it was
born in from the 80s but now we've all
kind of evolved as consumers of
entertainment and as storytellers as
well there's a lot more serialized
storytelling being done in terms of
animation I think it presents new
opportunities characters arcs can be
drawn out over a longer period of time
so you feel like you really know the
characters in an intimate way that you
can't do an episodic storytelling that's
a very exciting thing about cyberverse
we're excited about doing some of the
same thing with war for Cybertron it's
just generally speaking being able to
tell this universe in a serialized
narrative way it just gives so much more
opportunity to really flesh out these
characters
and make each story at home in a way
that you can't do when you're
22 minutes of episodic television I have
done what I have to do to end this
school
transformers war for Cybertron trilogy
first arc of Transformers war for
Cybertron is called siege and it's
really in many ways directly connected
to some of the events in generation 1 of
Transformers there's a civil war that's
been referred to many times throughout
the Transformers saga and siege actually
takes place on the last day of the Civil
War and so it's something that fans have
never gotten to see a period of time
that's pivotal in the Transformers
legacy and story that finally has been
put on screen it's you know a battle
that we we all know but haven't really
seen much detail before what I really
loved about bumblebee is David went back
earlier and I was really excited with it
or for Cybertron because we get to do a
little bit of that as well go back to an
earlier point tell something about these
characters or show you do things
to each other that's hopefully in
keeping with the rest of the continuity
and there was the series but maybe he
adds a little bit of a different
perspective a different you know color
to what you've seen before then Megatron
as a very evil and dubious plan that how
he can wipe out the Autobots once and
for all basically spark is a vessel of
life
[Music]
Megatron
there's no telling
what I loved about the story is that it
does pay homage to going all the way
back to generation 1 and it has some of
the elements that I really liked with
Autobots you see a lot of thinking about
how they should approach the war and how
they should approach the fight and
trying to be ethical and trying to
figure out what's the right thing to do
even if they have to make gigantic
sacrifices to save the day and do the
right thing and with the Decepticons
there's always more than meets the eye
as it's not just about their battle with
the Autobots there's all of this
internal kind of Makaveli and stuff
happening between the different
characters and you get the sense that
everyone there is always trying to get a
leg up on on each other I just love that
character dynamic because it gives much
more complexity and on the good side
they're weighing all these really tough
ethical dilemmas and on the Decepticons
bad guys side they're not only fighting
against the Autobots they're also going
through a lot of their own internal I
think all that complexity really
provides a lot of fun twists and turns
and plot development along the way
because we have this entire history
Transformers all these cool elements we
get to kind of like pick and choose you
know what to put in there and telling
stories about the different characters
where they've come from there's that are
relevant to the
but they're in at the moment going back
to be able to talk about this civil war
but also do it in the context of
flushing out some of these characters
that we all know and love and some that
maybe haven't gotten as much attention
in the past and also bring in all these
rich story elements that you know
sometimes movies for the first time
live-action movies sometimes in animated
movies in an other animated series
there's just a lot to play with and so
it was fun for us to be able to tell a
unique part of the history but have the
flexibility and luxury I guess you could
say of having such a rich universe to
draw from you know for us to be able to
show more of the Transformers history
and saga and bring it to screen was
really exciting you know visually we
look at what transformers generation 1
really accomplished in terms of setting
their style and tone and aesthetic the
colors that you know the palette and
just the iconic feel of these characters
we wanted to pay homage to all that and
felt like there was a lot of the early
artistic reference that we could draw on
luckily our supervising director had
worked on the original generation 1
cartoon so there was a lot of ingrained
knowledge there that you
to bring out but then another thing that
we really wanted to do is was modernize
the look and feel the
cartoons and you know take them into
this new era of enemy and adult
animation hopefully what's unique
visually about this series is that
you've got an animated story that uses
CGI and is a combination of references
going back to generation 1 of
Transformers all the way up through the
live-action film bumblebee and drawing
on bits and pieces of all that to
present something that is cinematic and
serialized and it gives you a lot more
I think character depth and complexity
and hopefully nuance to these characters
than you've seen before
we think of characters like Lolita Juan
and Optimus Prime they're just been
little tidbits of what her story was and
you know how she fit into the overall
picture but here I think in this series
you see her really being the heart of
the Autobot struggle and you see why
she's so important to the
decision-making mobility BOTS go through
how they
advance the story and how we have
important
[Music]
and that was every generation of
transformers I hope you learned a little
something about the Transformers
franchise it's a big world and now you
know how it inspired us in making war
for Cybertron thanks for watching